[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
can you believe it's been a whole three
weeks since we last had a meet-up I
think I've actually forgotten how to
make these videos well now we are in
week 14 of chapter 2 season 2 and the
end of season event is forming all
around us and things are getting a bit
spicy so sit your butt down for 10
minutes
slap colder tomorrow in the fort night
shop and let's go through all the
changes in this brand new update can you
guess where I'm gonna start
hut watch baby just like in the good old
days this famous construction has once
again grown and now includes the first
part of a staircase if you're new around
these parts here's the lowdown hot watch
was one of the greatest things our
community came together to celebrate
during chapter 1 but once we were thrown
through a black hole hot watch was gone
well there was this thing at Camp Cod
but that wasn't our Hut watch then over
the last four months we've watched two
haulage wagons slowly move around the
map in opposite directions one with
pallets on the back the other with
chairs and then came the day where they
passed one another on the road and
disaster struck both smashed together
and pallets and chairs flew everywhere
including down this hill but from that
dreadful act came the birth of hot watch
chapter 2 addition sheltered away from
the weather and out of sight of those
sweaty built battles at the moment it
looks like it's going to be the same as
the original hut watch so you are some
developers at Epic Games who watch this
series I have a request
could you make this hut watch different
from the first place in fact I have an
idea
creative players I challenge you to
build your own version of hot watch and
attempt to predict how it will be built
in game in fact we could make this into
a real video here's a potential title I
gave 10 for tonight creative builders
one hour to build Hut watch chapter 2
edition yeah like that if that sounds
like a video you'd watch please write
Hut watch forever in the comments and
I'll make that video with some of you
guys it could be pretty good and like
always I'm getting sidetracked my but
another thing of note is the cleanup
operation here both the truck on the
and the one below it by hot watch and
are ready to take away unwanted items
and hey maybe they'll crash into each
other and we'll get a ghost and a shadow
hot watch I think I just blew my own
mind moving on our next update sees the
scintillating scintillating you defend
known vs. teddy storyline here's what's
happening in the game right now it's a
great day for peace both sides have come
to a truce and are currently signing a
peace treaty I also love the touch that
he's wearing a bandage around his arm
how good is that pretty cool anyway
let's have a look at this new agreement
I'm sure it's profound notes one hide
away from stuff okay to find magic
things always good advice three get the
bacon for radio friends five stay inside
at night six get ammo and number seven
is the most important for all of us keep
clean I think we can all agree that this
is the greatest Accord since the Magna
Carta I hope you know what that is we've
come a long way from the day Graham sent
down his known Warriors to rescue a
prisoner from the ted-ed
overlords hiding down in The Woodlands
strategizing on a breach operation and
overthrowing the enemy before they broke
free and for a moment there it looked
like world war 3 was about to start good
thing you were around to stop that
happening GG you also note that they are
now sharing a drink and our best friend
little Norman is here he loves her knee
our Norman check him out number what am
I doing with my life
[Music]
each week I'm asked why I don't cover
certain areas of the island and to clear
it up a bit
that's because usually nothing can be
found there nothing has changed
occasionally I'm wrong you guys let me
know through Twitter DMS I really
appreciate that but to confirm this week
there is no change at the Ironman Ferris
Bueller's house is the same steam eastex
the shark the agency all look the same
we'll get to the agency very soon though
and even the golden chair story has
halted completely what we have to
remember is that the devs are working
from home right now they are doing their
job remotely and in my opinion they're
doing a damn good job but right now we
have something big something about the
end of season event have you been
keeping an eye on your Lobby screens the
doomsday device as seen in the back of
my das's room level at the agency is
slowly growing in power here's the three
updates everyone has received so far the
meeting room was once free of cabling
but last week a red band could be
spotted at the back at the top of the
room and in the latest update the energy
cables are now on the ground all around
the agency they are even plumbed down
into Midas's room if we visit him we can
see the energy flowing to of the
doomsday machine whatever his plan is
here it's coming together we all know
about those silos outside which I think
will destroy all the main Pio eyes
introduced this season like the grotto
but how will he do this well have you
seen the sky today
these are definitely new clouds okay
that's not news I understand but we can
read into this I decided to do a little
bit of geography research because I
couldn't remember a thing from school
and being the sad man that I am I now
know about cloud formations like
nimbostratus and altocumulus yeah I'm a
sad guy I first thought this was a cloud
which contained ice cold crystals but
then ghost from my discord told me about
roll clouds and check this out a roll
cloud indicates the start of a severe
thunderstorm could this happen in
fortnight could - be militarizing the
weather could the doomsday machine
actually be a weather machine bringing
drastic changes and brutal weather
conditions
or could this just be a nice fluffy
cloud added to the game maybe I'm
looking too deeply into this whatever
the answer looking in-game right now it
certainly seems like a rolling cloud is
forming a circle over the agency and
over those silos could we finally get a
natural disaster in game and this could
give the new chaos engine a reason to be
here to destroy buildings in game do you
remember the reveal of the chaos engine
it's all about destruction and how good
would fortnight be with more destruction
in game
let's hope they use it in the meantime
watch this guys speaking of weather
changes over the last few weeks these
phenomenons could be spotted in game
leading many of us to think the weather
is changing the island very slowly well
let's just quickly debunk them these
things have been here since the start of
chapter 2 the person who has shown you
these has simply cut down the bridge so
it looks like they are randomly
occurring but no they are just the
foundations of the bridge got it oh well
when you break it down like that it's a
little less impressive isn't it oh well
another tiny change at the island with
the crush plane upon it are the monitors
in the second section they've been
switched on again they've done this a
few times over the last three or four
months but I've never seen them go
anywhere with this I've kept this to
myself for a long time because I want it
to be the first person to spot something
on the screen but now I think the time
is to just open this up to everyone if
you see anything like Moss called
flashings or anything like that please
let me know i'm on twitter my name is
adam grenade so i think that's all the
map changes this week what have I missed
I'll be stocking in the comments to find
things as this could be the last update
of the season I'm going to cover a few
files that aren't in today's update but
are in the files if that makes sense I
don't want to spoil this for anyone
though so please click off right now if
you don't want to know things too early
are they gone good my favourite leaker
is fought Tory and him and his leaker
friends have identified new items in the
update for example the countdown for the
event has been found and will sit above
the agency like this
I wanted to bring this up because there
will be those click beta YouTube live
streams which will attempt to trick you
into watching a looped video I can't
believe this still happens in 2020 but
it does so pretty pretty please don't
get tricked and waste your time watching
a looped ten minute video made by
someone trying to trick the system into
getting paid before this becomes a rant
here's something cool the leakers have
found - a little fungus dude in the
files check out this cute little bugger
and on top of that there are loads of
new cosmetics and a new load screen
which I found very interesting called
storm the agency there's some Easter
eggs on this but I'm not covering them
just yet I don't want to dwell because
I'm not a leaker so we'll talk about
these in due course but if this is the
final update of the season
how cool is Fergus the fungus you can
have that name epic it's all yours
so then we have ate all the changes in
the world of fortnight this week as the
live event draws close I card mate I'm
so damn hyped for this on the screen now
are the awesome people who've used code
and amaru to grab something in the store
and then sent me a video of it over on
Twitter and by the way if you don't see
your name right now it's likely it's in
the other video I made which was going
to be released today before I knew about
this update I'll drop that one on Friday
- fortnight videos in three days Wow
I've changed as always thank you for
your time I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been an absolute pleasure
but watch forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]